t
toujours dans les plans mais qui
a été mis sur pause en raison de
insatisfaisants par le STM.
- C'est en 2009 que le projet
de service par bus, le SRB
par l'ancien maire
de Montréal, Gérald Tremblay
En 2015, des équipes ont été
mobilisées pour la conception
se sont amorcés.
- Yes!
(acclamation)
Et 14 ans et 523 millions
Pie-IX, voit enfin le jour.
Dès lundi, les usagers du
transport en commun pourront
circuler entre le boulevard'à
l'avenue Pierre-De Coubertinà M,
Transports, Mobilité durable, Qc
- Au quotidien, on parle
souvent, des fois, de projets
qui, pour lesquels il y a embuc,
des choses qui sont plus
corsées en matière de projets
d'infrastucture, mais là,
aujourd'.
VALÉRIE PLANTE,
mairesse de Montréal
- Il faut encourager
les gens à prendure
solo n'est plus soutenable
avec ou sans travaux
dans le pont-tunnel.
- Avec les embouteillages
attendusine, le développement
de cet axe routier Nord-Sud
améliorer le flux
de circulation.
YVES DESAUTELS, chroniqueur
- Ça peut désengorger un petit
peu, mais bon, parce que
les gens qui vont prendre
l'autobus Pie IX, normalement,
c'est pour aller travailler
- La ligne express 439 devrait
passer à un intervalle
de 4 à 10 minutes.
Pour un usager qui ferait
la route entre Henri-Bourass
de parcours diminuerait
de 10 à 15 minute
Sans le SRB, ce même trajet
prend en moyenne 40 minutes.
Alors, on se trouve à bord
du SRB Pie-IX. Donc, c'est
un premier test pour la ligne
express 439, ici, à Montréal,
et on s'attend à
rapide qu'à l'origine.
La construction de la voie aura
pris un peu plus de trois an
Une éternité pour certains
commerçants qui racontent
avoir frôlé la fa
du Resto Dèdèt
- Presque la faillite, maisonnee
aussi, à la fin, bien, qu'est-ce
qui m'a sauvé, c'est qu'ils ont
donné une petite récompense,
on pourrciation des commerçants
Pie-IX Montréal-Nord dit bien
accueillir l'entrée en fonction
du SRB. Jusqu'à 70 000 usagers
les estimations de la STM.
Ici Gabriel Proulx,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.